bienvenidos Soy Pedro Nelson Ruiz por
Natalia Cabrera esto es aquí América y
Estos son nuestros temas para hoy
se agudiza la crisis política en Ecuador
ante la posibilidad de ser destituido
por la asamblea nacional el presidente
Guillermo lasso activó la llamada muerte
Cruzada Qué implicaciones tiene este
mecanismo constitucional lo analizamos
el minutos
revuelo político en Colombia durante una
audiencia pública les comandante de las
llamadas autodefensas Unidas de Colombia
reitero ante la justicia transicional
los presuntos nexos de los paramilitares
con la clase política empresarial y los
militares del país revisamos algunas de
sus declaraciones
[Música]
golpe de la libertad de expresión en
Guatemala luego de más de 26 años de
existencia el diario el periódico
publicó su última edición este medio
llegó a su fin luego de que su director
fuera encarcelado sus cuentas fueran
congeladas y varios de sus periodistas
se vieran obligados a ir al exilio
Tenemos reporte
nuestra historia principal nos lleva a
Ecuador ya que se agudiza la crisis
política Guillermo lasso decretó la
llamada muerte Cruzada con lo que evitó
la posibilidad de llegar a ser
destituido por la asamblea nacional que
adelantaba un juicio político en su
contra con esta figura legal se disuelve
la asamblea se llaman a elección de
legislativas y presidenciales
anticipadas además durante un periodo
máximo de seis meses el jefe de estado
podrá gobernar bajo decreto para
analizar el contexto político que
atraviesa el Ecuador hablamos
previamente con Ana María Correa
profesora de ciencia política de la
universidad San Francisco de Quito quien
analizó el Por qué lazo decretó la
muerte Cruzada Y si activar esta medida
podría interpretarse como una victoria
de la oposición
el contexto político de esta semana en
Ecuador ha sido el de una semana muy
agitada en términos políticos
la situación del presidente Guillermo
lasso
estaba digamos al borde de la crisis No
es cierto ya sea porque iba a ser
destituido por la asamblea o porque si
es que no era destituido de todas
maneras tenía una debilidad política muy
fuerte Como para
llevar adelante y concretar las
iniciativas y los proyectos de ley que
necesitaba para su gobierno o por esta
última vía esta posibilidad que digamos
se concretó a través de la muerte
Cruzada lo que le da una esperanza de
vida
cortísima a su gobierno Entonces yo creo
que digamos cualquiera de los escenarios
era un escenario complejo para el
gobierno
digamos es Es difícil juzgar si es que
es una victoria de la oposición en el
sentido de que
cualquier gobierno que venga o si es que
el mismo presidente lazo se quedaba las
circunstancias del Ecuador en los
últimos meses son circunstancias muy
complejas
estamos atravesando una crisis de
seguridad muy fuerte
una crisis de violencia una crisis de
mafias vinculadas al narcotráfico que
están operando y que han ocasionado una
violencia nunca antes vista en el país
además analizamos si realmente existe en
Ecuador una grave crisis política y una
conmoción interna como para haber
activado la muerte Cruzada a ver existe
una grave crisis de inseguridad Sí
el juicio político en sí mismo tiene
cuestionamientos o tenía
cuestionamientos en cuanto a digamos la
forma en la que estaba planteado
el recurso de la muerte Cruzada que se
que se aplica por primera vez es un
recurso constitucional
paradójicamente previsto en la
constitución del 2008 hecha por el
gobierno de Rafael Correa
y aprobada por esa mayoría aplastante
que tenían en la en la Constituyente del
y tal y como está planteada digamos no
no requería de más autorización yo creo
que
digamos hay interpretaciones que se
pueden dar
a la situación yo creo que
digamos el juicio político
lo interesante es que abre digamos la
posibilidad a nuevas elecciones y en la
medida en que el gobierno lazo estaba
bloqueado políticamente
creo que es una es una salida digamos
interesante yo creo que quienes están
cuestionando digamos la idea de la de la
grave crisis interna Y de qué
calificativo se le daba esa crisis
también es porque tenían por ejemplo en
la asamblea unos bloques muy
interesantes que No necesariamente se
van a volver a repetir
en el futuro inmediato
en las elecciones que vamos a tener
ahora en cuarenta y cinco días o en un
año y medio
continuamos en Colombia ya que por
cuatro jornadas el ex líder de los
autodefensas Unidas de Colombia
Salvatore mancuso declaró ante la
jurisdicción especial para la paz
durante las audiencias públicas pidió
perdón a las miles de víctimas de estas
estructuras criminales pero el revuelo
político llegó tras los señalamientos
que hizo sobre presuntos nexos de los
paramilitares con la clase política
económica y las fuerzas armadas del país
Luis Muñoz con los detalles siendo esta
audiencia cuatro jornadas para la
historia de Colombia El ex líder del
temible grupo paramilitar autodefensas
Unidas de Colombia Salvatore mancuso
terminó el martes su comparecencia ante
la jurisdicción especial para la paz he
construido
esta manilla con mis manos en los
momentos de soledad en la celda
pensando en que cada uno de los puntos
de su bordado
hacen referencia al dolor al sufrimiento
al daño que causa a todos ustedes
quisiera
ofrendarlo como
[Música]
como un tributo a ustedes y una muestra
de mi arrepentimiento y vergüenza Muchas
gracias
la jep es una justicia restaurativa y
transicional surgirá en 2016 tras el
acuerdo de paz entre la guerrilla de las
FARC y el estado de Colombia esta
justicia juzga es guerrilleros y
militares pero como cuenta Camilo
González pozo en France 24 mancuso
podría acogerse a esta justicia se está
considerando un caso especial de mancoso
en tanto mancuoso pretende demostrar que
él era un enlace entre el ejército y los
paramilitares para combatir a la
guerrilla y para diferentes prácticas
criminales mancoso habló de la
financiación de campañas presidenciales
como la del expresidente Álvaro Uribe de
una fosa común en Venezuela de la
llegada de los paramilitares a la
capital a petición del ex vicepresidente
Francisco santos de la declaración de
objetivo militar por parte de la policía
secreta colombiana del actual presidente
Gustavo Petro así como de vínculos con
políticos medios de comunicación y
empresas en los próximos 30 días tendrá
que sustentar lo declarado con pruebas
de ser acogido en la jep Salvatore
mancuso que espera ser deportado tras
cumplir una condena de 16 años en
Estados Unidos podría llegar al país con
la libertad condicional
Argentina experimenta una inflación
anual superior al ciento ocho por ciento
y tiene niveles de pobreza que se
acercan al 40%. sus habitantes se
enfrentan las dificultades económicas
que hacen muy difícil planificar y
sostener a sus familias los ingresos en
general pierden frente al aumento de los
precios para saber cómo se vive la
situación en el país sudamericano
nuestro corresponsal en Buenos Aires
natalio cosoy nos envió este informe
manifestaciones como estas son
habituales en la capital Argentina en
esta ocasión fueron miles de personas de
organizaciones que representan a
sectores de bajos ingresos con empleos
precarios o que se sostienen con ayuda
Estatal que consideran insuficiente
no alcanza si bien A mí tampoco me
alcanza yo pago un alquiler y yo creo
que ninguno de los compañeros que están
acá tampoco les alcanza ellos pues
tienen hijos tienen cuatro cinco seis
chicos cada uno y no les alcanza el
economista guido Zack explica que en un
país con casi 40% de pobreza y precios
que aumentaron más de 108% en los
últimos 12 meses la alta inflación no
impacta igual en toda la sociedad esto
se ve claramente en el mercado laboral
entre el segmento informal y el segmento
formal el segmento formal que en general
tienen un salario promedio más elevado
es un segmento que es más que mal sigue
a la inflación y no tiene tanta pérdida
por adquisitivo el sector informal tiene
una pérdida de poder adquisitivo muy
significativa sin embargo el empleo en
el sector informal es el que más ha
crecido segmento del que forma parte
Pablo Julián Romero con algo de ayuda
Pablo comenzó un emprendimiento de
producción y venta de empanadas él es un
ejemplo de lo que le ha ocurrido a
muchos pasó del empleo formal y la
seguridad económica la informalidad
laboral y a vivir con lo justo desde el
2015 a esta parte que son 8 años
Yo fui como una la pendiente fue para
abajo Nunca fue para así que podría
haber sido y así no siempre fue
linealmente para abajo en mi caso hablo
Pablo tiene mucha expectativa de que el
negocio de las empanadas le permita
salir adelante y trata de no pensar en
la inestabilidad económica del país y la
amenaza que representa para proyectos
como el suyo en un duro golpe contra la
libertad de prensa al diario el
periódico que funcionó por cerca de 26
años en Guatemala emitió su última
edición este medio impreso cerró su
producción debido a la falta de ingresos
luego de que la justicia les congelará
las cuentas por el proceso judicial en
contra de su director José Rubén Zamora
que es acusado por presunto lavado de
activos y tráfico de influencias Andrés
Suárez Jaramillo corresponsal de Franz
24 para Centroamérica tiene los detalles
con un hasta siempre el periódico un
prestigioso diario de Guatemala ganador
del premio rey de España en 2021 al
medio más destacado de iberoamérica se
despidió de sus lectores tras 26 años de
existencia El ocaso del periódico se
atribuye a una persecución judicial
orquestada por el gobierno del
presidente Alejandro llama té y de
acuerdo con organismos que defienden la
libertad de expresión y los derechos
civiles varios hechos son en los que se
basan el primero es que el fundador del
periódico José Rubén Zamora se encuentra
preso desde hace 10 meses otros de sus
periodistas y columnistas están siendo
investigados por la fiscalía y algunos
otros han decidido decantarse por la vía
del exilio si bien el periódico publicó
al menos 144 investigaciones de
corrupción que empañan al actual
gobierno de acuerdo con analistas de
prensa hubo una publicación en
específico que habría colmado la
paciencia del ejecutivo se trata de una
columna de sátira al estilo de fábula en
la que se infiere que el presidente
yamate y habría saqueado al país para
regalárselo a su compañero sentimental
contados días después el 29 de julio de
2022 José Rubén Zamora fue detenido en
un extenso operativo policial cual si
fuera un temido narcotraficante sus
cuentas bancarias fueron congeladas
comenzó la crisis del periódico y le
bastó 10 meses para cerrar por completo
la fiscalía especial contra la impunidad
asegura que el proceso contra Zamora es
en su calidad de empresario más no de
periodistas sin embargo organismos
internacionales denuncian que es un caso
lleno de irregularidades que hace esta
un duro golpe al ejercicio del
periodismo en Centroamérica mientras que
voces más disidentes dicen que este es
un reflejo de que en Guatemala opera una
dictadura disfrazada de democracia
Gracias por acompañarnos en esta emisión
de aquí América pueden enviarnos sus
comentarios en redes sociales a la
dirección que ven en su pantalla en la
producción estuvo Jennifer Guevara y
pueden ver esta emisión y las anteriores
en nuestra página web trans24.com
[Música]